Hello, and welcome back to Rawkode Academy.
Today, we're continuing the complete guide to Kubescape.
Kubescape is a tool that allows you to
scan your Kubernetes manifest and clusters to detect
misconfiguration
and security violations
using
all the popular is that the right word?
Popular
security posture frameworks like MITRE,
SIS,
NSA,
ARMOR BEST, etcetera.
Today, we're gonna take a look at building
our own framework.
You can do this on easy mode with
ARMOR cloud, and we'll walk through exactly that.
However, I wanna dive in to what it
takes to build your own framework
on your own machine with your own JSON
and no cloud. But let's take a look.
Alright. Let's take a look at easy mode
first.
So this is ARMOR cloud,
which you'll have seen from the first two
videos in this course.
We're gonna click on my face and go
to settings.
From here, you'll see that I have three
inactive
clusters.
We're just gonna ignore that for today.
On the left, we have posture,
which has frameworks
and controls.
So let's click on frameworks.
Here, you'll see that we have all controls,
ARMOR best, DevOps best, MITRE, NSA and SIS.
We are gonna use the new framework button
to create our new framework.
See, I told you this was easy.
So let's name this Rawkode cloud.
I'm calling it Rawkode cloud because this is
the framework we are creating using the cloud.
And I don't want it to clash with
what we do on the command line shortly.
You can give it any description you want.
Funny. Right?
Next, you can select the controls
that you want to check for.
So let's search for host.
We want to ensure
that there is no host page access,
container host ports,
or host path mounts.
We click apply,
And if we scroll down,
we have Rawkode Cloud,
any description you want with three controls.
Now we can edit this whenever we want
and bring in new controls whenever we want.
Now why do I think this is important?
Well, I've worked
with a lot of I've worked with a
lot of teams that want to improve their
security posture,
but they can find the default policies overwhelming.
It can be quite intimidating when you see
that you have so many violations
across so many Kubernetes manifests across so many
Kubernetes clusters.
And what they want is just the easy
mode. Well, how do I just check for
like the really bad stuff?
Because you know, there may only be a
few rules that you wanna start out with,
but when you build
that habit,
you show people progress.
This kind of change becomes a lot easier,
especially when you're working with developers
who just may not be accustomed to this
terminology and smishy smashy language.
Now now that we've created our new framework
on ARML cloud, we can pull that down
to our local CLI.
Alright. Let's get started.
The first thing you need to do to
make your life a little bit easier on
the CLI is to export
KS
account
and set this to your account ID. If
you're not sure where to find that,
go to the cloud,
click your name,
and click copy.
Like so.
Now,
you can list
your frameworks.
And you'll see at the bottom, we have
Rawkode Cloud.
If you want to, you can cache these
offline
with download
artifacts.
And you'll see it's downloaded our Rawkode Cloud
and to the current directory.
So
if we take a look at the current
directory, we'll see all of the frameworks,
plus I have a deployment YAML,
some queue, and my own JSON.
We'll get to that in just a minute.
Let's run Kubescape
scan
Rawkode
cloud
dot.
I'm saying that I want to scan that
deployment dot YAML in this current directory
against my Rawkode cloud framework.
Now we can see the violations.
Now this is a very standard NGINX deployment
dot YAML. We don't have resource memory limit
requests, etcetera.
I'm not doing the good security stuff to
block privilege escalation
and I'm pulling it from a random Docker.
Well, I'm pulling it from the Docker Hub
registry. I don't have really any labels blah
blah blah blah blah. Thank you, Kubescape.
So
that's kinda cool.
And I would encourage you and I can't
stress this enough. I encourage you to use
ARMOR cloud,
build your frameworks from there, expand on them,
bake them into your CI process. We've already
done a video on CICD with Kubescape. So
go watch that next if you haven't already.
But
but
what if you want to do it the
hard way?
What if you want to build your own
framework locally
using your own tooling
without interacting with Rawkode?
Unfortunately,
this is all very undocumented and it took
a lot of reverse engineering and by reverse
engineering, I mean, just scrolling through GitHub code
to work out how this all works.
Let's build our own framework on the command
line.
Now why
am I gonna show you how to do
this
when building a framework is so easy on
ARMOR cloud?
Well, because I also wanted to explore and
experiment
with building my own controls.
ARMOR cloud is great for taking existing controls,
packaging them up, and iterating or expanding on
them to secure your security posture.
But if you want to write your own
controls, it really means
speaking to someone at ARMOR
or filing a pull request.
So
what if we just wanna iterate and hack
on locally?
So let's take a look at the ARMOR
best JSON that we got during the Kubescape
download artifacts.
And what we can see
is that a framework
is a JSON object. Now you probably already
knew that because you've seen the downloads when
I ran cubescape download. Yeah, nah, nah,
But it has an array object with controls.
Each of these controls
has some attributes which we can ignore for
now and some rules.
Then these rules
match against resources within our cluster
and then some other mumbo jumbo.
Let's take a look
at all controls.
Here we have forbidden container registries.
It too has some rules where it wants
to block
certain image registries.
Now you can see here that the language
for this rule
is Regal.
If you're not familiar with Regal, it's the
policy language from the Open Policy Agent project.
Now if you're thinking the existence
of this flag means, hey, cool. I thought
you thought that Ragel, maybe I can write
my policy in another language.
Unfortunately,
this is the code that runs your policy.
Ragel and Ragel two are the only supported
languages at the moment.
But maybe this will change in the future.
I think it would be kinda interesting to
see STARLARG or common expression language as an
option for right of policies.
Again, we match on the resources that we
want to apply this to.
And the last thing that we haven't really
covered
is that we have to rule itself.
Now this is just because the shift is
JSON. We have a complex string stored as
a string value. It has new lines as
tab characters, it has comments, it's got code.
This is not a pleasant experience to modify
your own custom framework and controls locally, but
again, again, it's not made to work like
that yet.
This is just me hacking around on stuff
that I shouldn't be hacking around on.
And I thought, well, what if we wrote
it in queue?
We could export the queue to JSON
and use the custom framework that way.
And that's the path that I went down.
Let's pop up in the queue.
I'm a big fan of queue.
It allows us to do cool things
that we can't do with JSON, YAML, and
other formats that we've been stuck with for
many years now.
So I encourage you all to go and
find Q tutorials online
and improve your data configuration lives.
First thing I do is I'm setting a
private variable.
Now I'm not going to go into queue
in a lot of detail, but understand that
a private variable is anything with an underscore.
When I run queue export,
that will be wiped off the face of
the planet.
We're using it to avoid a little bit
of duplication further down in the queue. Now
my usage of it here is relatively contrived,
but I wanted to show you one of
the small little perks of using queue for
this kind of tool chain.
We name
we name our framework,
and then we start to add controls.
I've called this control, you know, Rawkode Academy
images.
Description?
Well,
Rawkode Academy is risky. We don't trust them.
Remediation path? Don't use their images.
Once you have a control, a control has
rules.
Here we have our first rule called no
RKA
images,
and then we have a rule.
So already with q we have access to
multiline strings.
That means that we actually get a relatively
pleasant experience for editing
the Regal code.
It's worth pointing out that the q team
are working on embed like syntax similar to
what you get with Go embed.
Meaning, in the future, we'll actually be able
to do policy dot rego and load it
from its own file.
That's really cool because it means that we'll
get rego based syntaxing because it's in a
rego file.
So cool thing to look forward to in
the future.
Now if you're gonna go down the path
of writing your own controls this way,
there's a caveat. Remember,
it's not built to do this quite yet.
So you have to name your package ARMOR
built ins. This is just a caveat right
now.
I'll include an issue in the description if
you wanna track and see when that changes.
Other than that, you're right in straight up
Regal.
That means you can actually use the Regal
playground to test your policies or
even open Regal Toolchain locally.
It's up to you.
Here, we define untrusted image,
which pulls out the pod from our list
of resources.
We pull out the kind and make an
assertion that this is only gonna apply where
the kind equals a pod.
Next, we iterate
over all the containers.
Now iterators and Rego are a little bit
weird and you have to get used to
them. Just know that when we reference something
with a variable like I here,
we're gonna loop over that list.
All subsequent assertions will be against each item
and that list.
Next,
we pull out the path to help us
provide good debug and error messages for failing
policies.
We grab the image
and we call the RKA repo check function
against that image.
This function is extremely trivial.
We call the start of function to check
if our image starts with ghcr.i0/RawkodeAcademy.
If we get a failure,
we provide a message
that tells the user what went wrong,
and that's it.
We set the rule language to Rigo,
We tell it which resources to match against,
and we provide some description and remediation instructions
for this particular rule.
We have to provide a list of control
IDs at the bottom.
Hence, I'm using my private variable to loop
that in.
That's it.
So how do we run this locally?
Well, the first thing you're gonna want to
do is the q export
of Rawkode.q.
This now gives us a JSON object that
we can store locally and
I'm going to store this
in Rawkode dot JSON. We're now in a
position
where we can see Kubescape scan
use from, which means that we want to
use a local policy or framework,
and then specify in Rawkode dot JSON.
I'm then going to run that against my
deployment YAML,
and I'm just telling us to spell out
the results as JSON and a control format
rather than a resource format.
You now have our report dot JSON because
of our flags,
and we can see our high severity, no
Rawkode Academy images has failed on one resource
for the Rawkode framework.
Neat.
So as we can see, if we want
to remove this violation,
we can update our deployment dot YAML,
and we're gonna use a slightly more trusted
NGINX image.
Now we don't need all of these flags,
we just need use from and a scan
target like so.
And now we have no failed resource.
So this could be a really interesting way
to build up your own framework
with your own controls.
You can write your own Rego and ship
them via git.
You can hook this into your CI process
and improve your security posture
step by step,
control by control.
Now I do strongly encourage you just to
use ARMOR cloud, but if you need to
go down the custom controls path and custom
Regal,
that's just how to do it. So if
you found this useful or you need some
help, drop straight into the comment section.
Until next time, have a great day. I'll
see you soon.